the confirmation hearings for supreme
court nominee amy coney barrett are off
to an
incredible start and by that i mean they
have
no credibility there is no credibility
whatsoever
and the democrats incredibly are making
credibility
the issue beginning with one of the
least credible members of the u.s senate
democrat dick blumenthal president trump
and the republican setter are eroding
indeed destroying
[Music]
that legitimacy they've stripped
the american people of their say in this
process simply to confirm
a justice who will strike down in court
legislate from the bench what they can't
repeal
in congress
your participation let me be very blunt
in any case involving donald trump's
election
would immediately do explosive enduring
harm to the court's legitimacy and to
your
own credibility you must
recuse yourself danang dick blumenthal
is warning judge amy barrett about
threats to her legitimacy
dick blumenthal very famously lied about
his service in the vietnam war
dick blumenthal very famously called our
last supreme court nominee
a gang rapist take a listen to what he
said when brett kavanaugh
was up for the court this
affidavit sworn with
immense detail and
corroborating witnesses who will come
forward
this woman a survivor of vicious
sexual attack has everything to lose
her livelihood depends on her security
clearance if
she is found by the fbi to be lying
she loses her livelihood if my
republican colleagues have
any sense of
morality they will refuse to go forward
on friday
they will demand an fbi investigation
and in fact the white house should do so
if
judge kavanaugh is really serious about
clearing his name
he should demand an fbi investigation of
these
detailed precise absolutely
staggering allegations absolutely
staggering shortly after denang dick
made those comments by the way the
allegations completely fell apart
those were not the christine ford
allegations those were the
julie swetnick allegations which had no
basis in reality no evidence at all
and the lawyer who pushed them is now
serving hard time for fraud
that's where the credibility is
unfortunately for guys like
dick blumenthal who can push this all
out there with a straight face
it's not even convincing their own
colleagues the democrats
know that they are losing here and
they're going to try to get through
these hearings
as quickly as possible i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from hudson dean
lebron james cares so much about gender
equality
that the nba now has the same ratings as
the wnba
that is wow you know because we've just
been talking about
all the racial division the left is
pushing but you're right that is
on the the level of sexual politics as
well there are
there are now just as many people
watching the nba
as the wnba well that's that's a great
value isn't it you know those two things
used to have
very different uh revenues and now it
looks like those revenues it looks like
the money coming into both of those
organizations
is just about the same you got to make
sure that you're not overpaying you're
going to make sure you got to level out
those revenues
when you are paying your cell phone bill
and that is why i would highly recommend
puretalk usa
i'm going to be extremely blunt here if
your cell phone plan
is with say verizon att or t-mobile
you are paying way too much for the
exact same coverage
that you would be getting right now with
puretalk now i know what you heard me
say what you heard me say is if you have
att t-mobile verizon
you can get a similar network you get
similar coverage for the for a cheaper
i didn't say that i said you could get
the exact same
the exact same the average person who
switches to pure talk
is using less than four gigs of data per
month but the big carriers are charging
you for unlimited data that's how pure
talk saves the average person
over 400 per year on their wireless
service unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data all for just
20 a month
and if you go over on data usage guess
what they don't charge you for it
they won't charge you for it it's
unbelievable how much money people are
throwing out the window on
other cell phone companies when you can
get the same service grab your mobile
phone dial pound 250 say michael knowles
when you do you will save 50 off your
first month dial
pound 250 and say keyword michael
knowles pure talk simply
smarter wireless now we will move into
something that is simply
dumber which is these confirmation
hearings that we were watching yesterday
even the left is admitting that this is
not going well for them cnn cut away
during the confirmation hearings and the
reason they cut away i don't think is
because
they're making some principled stand on
the legitimacy of trump nominating a
judge during election year
they're cutting away because there's no
way this is a win for democrats
how do they win they can either pull a
cavanaugh they can
viciously attack this woman and try to
derail her nomination
but how is that going to look a few
weeks before a presidential election
you've got this
very attractive both physically and on
paper
sort of nice female candidate part of
the gentler sex
with this big beautiful family totally
unimpeachable
so you can have the last taste in voters
mouths of democrats be them
just destroying this very sympathetic
woman
or they can fail right or the democrats
don't derail her nomination
and they look feckless on screen either
way it looks pretty
pretty bad and it looks like right now
democrats are trying to split the baby
as it were very very literally trying to
split the baby by
derailing uh justice barrett and trying
to maintain roe versus wade
so they're trying to have it both ways
and it's it's not
working very well most of the hearing
was just
senators letting out the hot air that
generally tends to fill their
bodies but a few tried to make cogent
arguments and it went nowhere kamala
harris was first up
kamala harris was testifying remotely
and she had a picture of rbg this kind
of silly rbg children's book behind her
and she said the reason we can't confirm
barrett is because barrett
will undermine justice ruth ginsburg's
legacy
by replacing justice ruth bader ginsburg
with someone who will undo her legacy
president trump is attempting to roll
back
americans rights for decades to come
every american must understand that with
this nomination
equal justice under law is at stake
our voting rights are at stake
workers rights are at stake consumer
rights
are at stake the right to a safe and
legal abortion
is at stake and holding corporations
accountable
is at stake and again there's so much
more
so only two things she said were true
the rest of it was completely bogus but
i do give her credit for saying the two
true things she said a lot of silly
things like our right to vote is at
stake
i don't think so i think we'll be able
to vote even if there's another judge on
the bench
there's a new judge replacing rbg she
says things like corporations will
finally be held to account
corporate america supports the left
overwhelmingly okay there's
there's no threat being posed by a
conservative judge
uh to to you know your consumer choice
if anything it will having a
conservative judge on the bench will be
a negative turn of events for corporate
america and a positive thing
for consumer protections and for smaller
businesses
but she says two things that are true
one justice barrett
could overturn ruth ginsburg's legacy
that is true that's the point that's why
we're nominating
that's why we have conservative judges
the point of conservative judges
is to undermine the legacy of left-wing
judges the point of left-wing judges is
to undermine the legacy of conservative
judges
that's it that's the way it works kamala
harris would do exactly the same thing
so
totally fine and i'm not even sure by
the way i don't know
what justice barrett's really going to
do conservative judges
disappoint the people who appoint them
all the time
so we're hoping knock on wood she
undermines ginsburg's legacy and then
i have to give kamala harris credit she
said that ruth
or amy barrett rather could undermine a
right
quote unquote that ruth ginsburg
protected namely the right to abortion
that's true right that is the issue i
actually give kamala harris a little bit
of credit because
so often we just hear them use this
euphemism women's health
reproductive rights which are
not only imprecise but in the case of
reproductive rights the opposite of what
is true
it's the opposite of reproduction but
that's it this is about abortion
democrats are turning abortion into a
sacrament they're making this
the central issue of their campaigns
which is pretty creepy
and we are trying to overturn that yep
and i hope justice barrett does it
not sure that she will that was the best
comment i could muster next up was amy
klobuchar
who was even less convincing than kamala
harris because klobuchar realized there
was no
lane of attack she wasn't going to go
after barrett's religion she's too smart
for that
she wasn't going to go after barrett's
kids she's too smart for that
she wasn't going to issue in these sort
of stupid
platitudes about just broad issues like
kamala harris did
so klobuchar decided to pivot back get
away from the court issues entirely
and for some reason start talking about
coronavirus
the daughter of among refugees whose
parents fled laos
to a refugee camp in thailand before
arriving in minnesota
marnie and her seven siblings grew up in
st paul
their family the american dream
this is who this virus has taken from us
someone who has left behind
a mother and a father and seven siblings
who loved her
and someone who undoubtedly would have
made the world a better place
the president could have saved so many
lives instead he's been reckless
packing people in without mass for your
nomination party judge barrett
35 people got sick the president himself
ends up in the hospital
and when he leaves walter reed still
contagious he defiantly takes off his
mask
and walks into the white house and then
he lies and says the
virus will magically go away the truth
matters and the truth is america that
this judicial nominee has made her view
so clear
and this president is trying to put her
in a position of power
to make decisions about your lives
uh what
she tries to bring it back there at the
end to this
this president is trying to nominate a
judge who will make decisions about your
lives
you know like all presidents who
nominate judges because those are
judges what judges do this president is
trying to nominate a judge like the
constitution says
he should so she tries to bring it back
there at the end but
what she's talking about coronavirus and
this these very sad stories about people
who've died from coronavirus have
nothing to do with
washington d.c or trump or barrett and
then
it's trump's fault that there is a virus
from china or something and then
and but he's nominating a judge and so
that's bad too
this speech i don't know what staffer
wrote this speech but whoever wrote it
should be fired
this would not pass a freshman writing
seminar a freshman in high school
writing seminar
this was pretty weak sauce but she does
it because
they have nothing else i felt
klobuchar's
speech speechifying yesterday was the
clearest evidence
that the democrats know they've got
nothing the left know they are losing on
this issue
and they just need to move past this
hearing they'll do the sort of
perfunctory yelling and howling
but they'll just they'll confirm her and
then they'll move past it because
there's no way that they gain
politically here someone who was was
just as convinced
or just as confused rather as the rest
of us over
amy klobuchar's bizarre rant was
senator ben sasse one thing you might
have noticed about senator sasse i think
one of the most persuasive
aspects about the guy is he's got very
good hair
and if you want to keep your hair you've
got to check out
hymns hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves
with licensed medical providers and fda
approved products
to help treat hair loss no snake oil
pills
no gas station counter supplements hems
connects you to licensed medical
professionals online
which could save you hours completely
confidential completely discreet
you know me i'm not a i'll just say it
i'll say it with no
no false modesty here i'm not a hulking
adonis of a man okay
one thing that always helped me in the
lady department was that you know i got
a nice full head of hair so i'd
recommend you go do that today today
hymns
is giving you their best offer yet if
you're not happy with your results after
90 days hymns will give you
a full refund right now my listeners can
get their first visit absolutely free go
to
for hims.com knowles canadawlis
that is for hims.com knowles
full refund of price paid available for
first 90 days supply refund request must
be made
between 90 and 180 days after product
shipment is delivered prescription
products require an online consultation
with a medical professional who will
determine
if a prescription is appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety information
remember what is it for hymns hims.com
knowles so ben sasse who has very nice
hair
was just as confused as the rest of us
and so he took the opportunity to offer
a civics lesson for our obviously
degraded
national conversation senator klobuchar
said
a number of things about kovid that i
agree with
she cited a bunch of really painful
stories in minnesota and similar stories
could be told from across the country
i even agree with parts of her criticism
of the mismanagement of covid by
washington d.c
i don't know what any of that has to do
with what we're here to do today
huge parts of what we're doing in this
hearing
would be really confusing to eighth
graders if civics classes across the
country
tuned into this hearing and tried to
figure out what we're here to do
and they heard as much as they've heard
about 2009
finance committee debates about what
should be in a health care reform
package
i i'm blessed to sit not just on the
judiciary committee
but also on the finance committee and
lots of the discussions we've had in
here today fit better in a finance
committee hearing than a judiciary
committee hearing
so i think it would be very useful for
us to pause
and remind ourselves and do some of our
civic duty to 8th graders
to help them realize what a president
runs for
what a senator runs for and on the other
hand why judge barrett is sitting before
us today
this was an excellent skewering of what
was going on and it actually what
ben sass is doing here is exactly what
senators should do
he's he's distilling this for eighth
graders and
in there as a kind of not-so-subtle jibe
at the democrats which is saying you
guys
are behaving not even as 8th graders
would
you guys do not even possess the civic
understanding of 8th graders and it's
important to have civics education we no
longer have it in schools
isi the intercollegiate studies
institute did a survey of
elite university students so the top top
ranked schools in the country
this was all the way back in 2007 by the
way they surveyed seniors
and freshmen turned out that graduating
seniors knew less about civics than
incoming freshmen
let's say people are getting more
ignorant over time
so it's important to have that civics
education but this is also what senators
should be doing
you know most of our government is just
run by bureaucrats
it's not actually run by the elected
president or the senators or
even even the judges more so the judges
but but
certainly not these elected guys in
congress in the senate much of what
the senate and the house of
representatives exist to do
is to communicate politics to people
it's kind of a sad state of affairs
because they actually have
significantly less law making power than
they used to
most of that has been sent away to the
administrative state
so the one thing they can do is
communicate
and bring people in on what is happening
in their government and that has a
little bit of
of accountability therefore to their
constituents
that's what sas was doing i thought it
was a brilliantly done
we could all use a good civics lesson
most especially the democrats
sitting in that chamber now he he opened
up by kind of
poking fun at what amy klobuchar was
demagoguing about this this covid
narrative
and these coveted stories as a way to
distract from what they were actually
supposed to be doing
it is important to note that the
democrats narrative on coronavirus right
now
is completely falling apart it's never
made sense
the the rules have been changing
constantly initially we were told
by the experts by the surgeon general by
dr fauci the exulted dr fauci peace be
upon him
by elected democrats like eric swalwell
all these guys were saying don't wear
masks masks are stupid you must be an
idiot if you're wearing a mask
don't don't wear them stop buying them
then we were told
you have to wear masks all the time
masks are super duper effective
if you even suggest that mac's masks are
not used perfectly all the time
then you're going to be kicked off of
the internet then we heard from
for instance epidemiologists at columbia
said this to npr that the masks
fail in studies but not because the
masks are no good because people don't
use them correctly which i suppose makes
sense right people are
putting the masks on they're touching
their face they're moving around they're
not wearing it right
there's a new study out from the cdc
guess which percentage what is the
percentage of people who are
infected with coronavirus according to
the cdc
study who wore their masks
all the time or often what percentage
would you say because you know the
matter they're so
so good at protecting you from the virus
what percentage
two percent three percent are wearing
their masks all the time or often
and still get the virus 85
85 according to this recent cdc study
70.6 of respondents report that
they always wear a mask an additional
14.4 percent
say that they often wear a mask which
means 85 percent of people
who have been infected with coronavirus
according to this study
habitually wear the mask now here's the
kicker
what percentage of people according to
the cdc study
report never wearing the mask who then
go on to get coronavirus
3.9 percent so for me
you know my behaviors on these sorts of
things but look for me i'm an expert
scientist so i just want to follow the
science
i want to listen to the cdc i want to do
whatever the experts tell me to do
and it seems from the cdc study
that some of what we've been told about
these precautions is not correct well we
know
we know that some of what we've told
about these precautions is not correct
because the so-called experts
have told us opposite guidance
they've told us never wear the mask
they've told us always wear the mask
and now as we learn more about the way
these things work
it would seem that it's even more
confusing
after this cdc study though there's
another survey
that came out of chicago which gives us
a little hint on
how this coronavirus is going to be
spreading throughout the populations
you know this is a real threat i don't
mean to downplay the threat
we do have to consider our safety
not just by the way in the realm of
public health also
in the realm of home security and
whether people are going to try to come
in
and steal your stuff that's why you got
to check out ring there are a thousand
reasons
why protecting your home should matter
to you ring has security products for
every corner of your home inside and out
best of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep
an eye on your home no matter where you
are right from your phone you know that
i give
ring out to my friends as housewarming
gifts so
recently i've been getting updates on
some of my friends who have have the
ring that i've given them
and one couple very close friends of
mine they have this cute little baby
so they'd leave the you know they go out
with the baby they put the baby on the
grass they find out thanks to their ring
there's a coyote living in their yard
and come
comes in and out and so they see this
now they say okay god i've got to keep
an eye on my kid
when he's out here in the yard now what
i imagine this has led to
is the baby just kind of watching his
ring and then turning into
the roadrunner you know and just kind of
tricking this coyote and having like
grand pianos fall from the sky and then
the coyotes teeth or the keys
this is just what i'm imagining i
haven't seen this on the ring yet but
you can keep an eye on your home as well
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com
knowles includes rings video doorbell 3
and chime pro the perfect way
to start your ring experience plus free
two-day shipping go to ring.com
knowles ring.com knowles
so the cdc study shows the
overwhelming majority of people who are
getting infected with coronavirus
are wearing the masks always or often
again that's not saying anything about
the masks per se
just telling you how this virus is
actually spreading
in reality well we see the same thing in
chicago right now
they did a survey in chicago of how many
residents who sent blood spot samples to
northwestern university researchers
tested positive for covid antibodies
so they had people sort of send in these
samples and they're going to see
not even just how many people have the
virus currently but how many people have
the antibodies so
they had the virus in the past do you
know how many chicagoans
have had coronavirus according to this
survey
one in five a full 20
of chicagoans who sent in these samples
have had coronavirus this was my point
when when we were talking earlier
i've been reiterating this almost once a
week now
the liberals think that conservatives
oppose all of their kind of crazy
measures
to stop the spread of coronavirus
because we think we're never going to
get coronavirus but actually the
opposite is true
we oppose them well one because there is
some dispute over the efficacy of some
of these measures
two now in the case of the lockdowns the
world health organization is actively
saying don't do the lockdowns the
lockdown's very bad for you
but disputes about the efficacy of these
things aside
the reason that we are not
indulging this sort of thing and
clamoring to throw the world into a
global economy or into a global economic
depression
over the coronavirus measures is because
not that we think we won't get it but
because we know
kovid's here to stay we're very likely
going to get it
w.h.o came out the other day and said
one in 10 people on earth
has gotten coronavirus 10 of the entire
world population
has gotten this virus in the 9 or 10
months that it has
existed it's not going to stop there
folks
it's gonna keep spreading one in five
chicagoans has had coronavirus
i know you think that you can protect
yourself from that forever
because there's some government policy
some matter of social engineering that's
gonna protect you from germs
that now we're on a a political crusade
to to defeat
germs you're not going to do it it's not
going to happen folks
this is this is not only as foolish as
say the war on poverty you know
or the war on this or the war on that
this is more foolish
you will not defeat disease you can
improve health
you can mitigate disease you can develop
vaccines that have certain efficacy
great i encourage everybody to do that
you will not eliminate disease from the
world you will not
bring your risk down to zero percent
which is what i think our utopian
friends
on the progressive left think that
they're going to do
and notice by the way our utopian
friends they always change the rules
so first obviously with the masks it was
so obvious because
they said don't wear the masks and then
they said do wear the masks but even
with the
social distancing one of the creepiest
phrases i've ever heard
social distance together apart
these are opposite things they say okay
if you're six feet apart you're totally
fine
if you're six feet at one point they
told us if you're six feet apart you
don't need a mask
then we were told by some people if
you're 6 feet apart you do need a mask
then it's become 10 feet apart so the
chief of staff at the white house mark
meadows
comes down he's speaking to reporters
and he the microphone's near the
reporters so what does he do he pulls
the microphone back
10 feet away so that he doesn't get them
all upset
and then he takes his mask off to speak
to them these
wusses have a meltdown
tell you what let me do this let me pull
this away pull away
and then that way i can
take this off to tie well i'm more than
ten feet away
i'm not well i'm not going to talk
through that
i'll be glad to answer your question
damn right damn right i'm not going to
talk through a mask
i am not going to perform whatever
liturgy of liberalism you were trying to
foist on me
with no scientific basis that you're
even trying to
present even if there were a scientific
basis we would still have to debate
whether or not we want to engage in that
sort of thing
as a matter of politics and ethics
but you're not even present what
scientist is saying that if i'm standing
10 feet away
i have to wear this cloth mask or else
we're all going to die no one is saying
that
so he says okay you what you just want
to muzzle me you just want me to look
foolish
some people say well mr meadows
why not do it why not put the mask on
even if you're standing 10 feet away
even if when you start giving your press
conference you're going to sound like
that teacher from the peanuts
cartoonsville
i should be clear from how it sounds why
he shouldn't do that
but more broadly to this point of
why don't you just do it it's not hard
it's not hard why don't you do it
what if the reporters said to mark
meadows hey mark meadows
it would make us all feel a lot better
if you put a doughnut on your head
i said what yeah mr meadows we want you
to put a donut on your head
say there's i don't think there's any
evidence that having a doughnut on my
head
is going to help you all in any way
whatsoever
okay maybe there's not maybe there's not
evidence but it would make us feel
better so put the doughnut on your head
put the doughnut on your head right now
what this has become
is now it would seem very very
separate from a scientific conversation
this is an
exercise in imposing one's political
will
the world health organization came out
and said do not do the lockdowns we
still have lockdowns why
because power hungry
demagogues want to flex
their political power and their
political will on you
it doesn't even have to have an object
it doesn't even have to have a point
a specific point to the flex the flexing
itself is enough
and that is what the press corps was
trying to do to mark meadows yesterday
i'm very glad that he did not take the
bait on this
now some in the press are trying to reel
this kind of stuff back they realize it
doesn't play particularly well
cnn i don't know what's going on in cnn
they're actually trying to moderate in
the past few days
you had jake tapper now you have this
this woman on this anchor on cnn
who is talking to senator maisie hirono
one of the least impressive members of
the senate
and cnn actually fact checked a democrat
and that you haven't seen that a whole
lot you haven't seen
facts really rise to the top of the
conversation though if you do
one factorized at the top of the
conversation you've got to check out the
benham brothers
you know small businesses have taken a
big hit since march and many of them are
still feeling the effects of the
lockdowns
jeremy boring you know very well the god
king over here jeremy's had some
troubles during this
coronavirus lockdown dailywire has had a
number of crises in its history
but daily wire has been able to weather
them not just in covid but before that
as well
and right now they want to share their
wisdom
jeremy is going to be presenting a long
time alongside a team of world-renowned
business leaders
at expert ownership live a two-day
virtual conference about leading through
crisis the conference features a lineup
of speakers such as leadership author
john maxwell the founders of duck
commander and otterbox
the benham brothers and many others who
can relate to what entrepreneurs and
leaders are going through
right now this conference is one of
those investments that your business
will thank you for
in the long run go visit
expertownershiplive.com
knowles to register for 147 dollars and
you can buy a second ticket for a friend
fifty percent off
and you get to see jeremy i don't know
if that's gonna sell it i don't know if
that's gonna hurt sales
either way though you know look jeremy's
got a lot of wisdom that is expert
ownership live dot com slash knowles buy
one ticket for 147 dollars
get one for 50 off expert ownership live
dot com slash knowledge kwls also it's
baseball season the old glory daily wire
baseball bat is back you know we
had these very briefly very limited run
just for all access members
and they sold out within 48 hours it's a
very cool bat
custom painted with the daily wire logo
emblazoned on it
well it is back my friends now anyone
can purchase it
inventory is limited though so you got a
text baseball
a l b-a-s-e-b-a-l-l to h three four zero
zero that is
eighty three thousand four hundred that
is eight three four zero zero text
baseball to purchase your bet today
we'll be right back with a lot more
credit where credit is due cnn actually
just fact
checked a democratic senator on the air
macy hirono
was throwing around the phrase court
packing which
specifically means adding justices to
the court by
increasing the number of justices right
it does not mean
filling vacancies which is not only a
constitutional right it's a
constitutional requirement
court packing is a different thing when
you increase the number of justices so
she was throwing this word around
and cnn very gently very secretly
corrected her on the air i mean
obviously just
filling a vacancy right now is not what
is normally referred to as court packing
it's adding seats but i think that
you've said that you're open to that as
well
there are a number of uh things that we
can talk about to reform the course
including by the way you know we should
apply
strict ethics standards to supreme court
justices
we don't have that so there are any
number of things that we can talk about
to make sure
that the supreme court is not an
ideologically
determinative body which by the way if
you look at their recent decisions many
many five to four decisions
that are very much partisan and
ideologically based that is not what we
want the supreme court to be in fact
that's not how we want our entire
judiciary to be
they should be objective independent
not filled as i said with people who
have an ideological
agenda we don't want people on the court
who have an ideological agenda that's
why we've got to keep all the
conservatives off and put all the
leftists on
macy hirono can't take the hint from
this woman on cnn he's saying like hey
macy maybe
here's a better way to go about this
we're all on the same team here maisie
but
you're not doing this very well it's
it's funny too because
when she's talking about the ideological
conformity of the court
let's not forget the leftist judges
almost
100 of the time vote together
even on cases that are constitutionally
preposterous
whereas the conservative judges often
split apart break away disagree with one
another
i'm not even making a point about how
the conservatives are right and the
leftists are wrong i'm just saying as a
matter of ideological conformity which
is what mesiarone is talking about
the left is purely ideological
ideologically unified and the right
breaks up and has disagreements and
someone's an originalist and someone's a
textualist and the textualist disagrees
with the originalist on this i mean just
in this recent supreme court term
you had huge disagreement on the right
so if maisie wants
intellectual diversity on the court i
guess she's got to go for the
conservatives but she's going to
she's probably not going to do that she
probably doesn't even understand the
point
the reason i think that cnn is willing
to
play this a little softer now the reason
that cnn is even willing to maybe gently
correct a democratic senator
is not because they've had some wake-up
call not because they
understand that the left is harming the
country
it's because they understand that the
left is losing they're losing
right now maybe it doesn't seem like
that because the media is putting on a
good show
maybe it doesn't seem like that because
who knows how the presidential election
is going to turn out
but broadly speaking on this argument on
the court argument on the
amy coney barrett argument on the
radicalism argument
the left is losing
here's an important poll we've been
reading some of the polls all the time
here's an important one that doesn't
even mention the phrase
trump or biden but it tells you a lot
and i
suspect it might have something to do
with the election gallup
asks people are you better off now than
you were four years ago
this was ronald reagan's famous line in
a presidential debate gets up there he
goes well
he's got jimmy carter over here you've
got to ask yourself one simple question
are you better off now than you were
four years ago
right because that's the that's that's
what you have to know if you're
if if you're running against an
incumbent you say you're better off now
than you were four years ago
and the answer is no then you got to
vote for the alternative and if you are
the incumbent
are you better off now than you were
four years ago
well the answer better be yes the answer
for this incumbent president trump is
yes 56
of people in a survey taken september
14th through the 28th
which obviously is way into the
coronavirus lockdowns right this is not
while the economy was still booming
this is very recently this poll was
taken and still even with the
country shut down the economy tons of
people out of work
are you better off now than you were
four years ago 56 americans say yes
they are better off they are better off
even in a pandemic under trump
than they were under obama that's
compared to just
under a third 32 percent who say that
they are not
better off than they were four years ago
how about on the other degrees of
radicalism obviously we have blm
burning down the country that doesn't
play very well for the left but even on
some of these
these wacky sexual issues
they divide us on race they divide us on
sex on the sexual issues i don't think
this is playing well in peoria
i'll give you just an example there's a
book review out in the new york times
called
are straight people okay and other
questions about love and sexuality
based on some book castigating marriage
here's just a quick line
in examining the pressure to partner
with the opposite gender we find the
extortions of capitalism the misogyny of
violence against women
the racist and xenophobic erasure of
non-white
families and the homophobic hatreds
that pervade so much of everyday life
this is not outlier in in leftist
discourse
this is not an outlier this is the
mainstream this is what you see
broadcast during these crazy rallies
this is even what you see
on presidential debate stages among the
democratic party remember when
julian castro when he was still running
for president
he said we need to support abortion
rights we need to support abortion
justice not just for women but for trans
women
meaning men who put on dresses
who i guess can have abortions now i
don't know how that's possible
this kind of gobbledygook of leftist
jargon
the misogyny of violence against women
racist xenophobic erasure of non-white
family how do you what huh what is that
homophobic hatreds and blah blah blah
complete complete fictive gobbledygook
and i think
a lot of americans who are not steeped
in this kind of radical ideology look at
that and say huh
i got one guy telling me make america
great again i got one guy
talking to me about the erasure of the
cis
trans non-binary non-white
misogynistic blah blah blah blah blah
i think i'm going to vote for that guy
the one who i can understand you know
the one who's speaking
simple english who says like don't burn
down the country yeah i think that guy
that guy is more persuasive this is how
president trump
who has many personal foibles
was able to win in 2016. this this is
what the media didn't get a lot of the
never trump right never understood
this they thought that president trump
won
because he's got this mean personality
he's a real angry
mean cruel guy and he won in spite of
the policy offerings and his kind of
basic view of the country
it was the opposite ann coulter wrote a
great book about this with a very funny
title in trump we trustee pluribus
awesome
but it actually was a pretty pretty
solid book and made a very good argument
which is people voted for trump often
in spite of his personality because of
his policies
because he said make america great again
that's not a trump original he took that
from ronald reagan
but trump has a good ear he has a good
ear for the culture and he realizes that
that idea resonates they voted for trump
might be talking about mika brzezinski's
face and maybe that's
a little distasteful but he hugs the
american flag and he says he's going to
protect manufacturing jobs
other republicans we're not going to
protect manufacturing jobs
he loves the country and he says you
know we all bleed the same blood of
patriots and
we should have no racial division but
also we should have a national border
other republicans we're not really
saying that as much
that kind of common sense rings a lot
truer i think you know on this on this
issue of the crazy sexual politics
there is a truly disturbing story just
came out of iowa
there was a little girl in iowa whose
parents
were nerdy wells and so she was going to
be adopted
by her great-grandparents this
one-year-old girl so her great parent
grandparents had to apply to the state
just to make sure this paperwork worked
because
the kid's parents were not able to take
care of her
the united states
uh district judge reversed this decision
to allow the great grandparents to take
care of her holding that the state
regula
so so i'm sorry let me rewind you've got
the kid who's going
to the state the foster system
the great great the great grandparents
try to adopt the kid it's a little bit
confusing
then the state comes in and says no you
can't adopt the kid
because you have oppressive sexual views
here are some of the questions
that they had to answer according to the
political correct
orthodoxy if they wanted to adopt their
great granddaughter how would we react
if the daughter was a lesbian
would we allow the daughter to have a
girl spend the night at our home
as our girl's romantic partner if at 15
years old
this little girl wanted to undergo
hormone therapy to change her sexual
appearance
would we support that decision and
transport her for those treatments
if as a teenager this little girl wanted
to dress as a boy and be called a boy's
name would we accept her decision
and allow her to act in that manner
if you don't say that you are willing to
let your
adopted daughter have her lesbian
girlfriend come and sleep over at age 15
if you don't say that you will allow
your adopted daughter to
inject hormones into herself to appear
cosmetically more like a boy
now according to the idaho
department of health and welfare you're
not allowed to adopt that daughter
goodness gracious thankfully as i as i
mentioned another government agency came
in namely that the judiciary actually
came in and reversed that decision for
now
for now how long before this is
replicated all over the country
idaho i thought was a pretty
conservative place i mean imagine
you know when i was a kid if i was 15
and i said hey mom i want my girlfriend
to spend the night
she would have smacked me [ __ ] are you
kidding me but now
now this is a human right i guess you're
not allowed to adopt otherwise
i think people are looking at some of
those stories and saying
this is not the country that i want to
live in and
i don't care what donald trump tweets
and i don't care how nice good old joe
looks if those are the two
visions of america i want to go with
make america
great again that's what people are
showing joe biden on the campaign trail
joe biden was just doing an event in
toledo ohio he came out he gave his kind
of stump speech
and trump supporters chanted four more
years
in the background but all kidding aside
tony thank you for hosting us
and thank you for local 14. and kenya
and you can hear some horns it's a
little hard to hear because it's off
microphone here four more years
four more years who knows how big this
crowd was i imagine
it was relatively relatively small so
it's not looking good for joe biden and
some leftists are getting irritated by
this
you're seeing the radical left trying to
push all this crazy gobbledygook about
how you've gotta
trans your kid and how you've got to
you know do all of these extraordinary
radical measures and then you've got the
more moderate wing like allison
i think was allison camerata whoever it
was on cnn saying hey come on
stop saying that stuff maisy don't go
that far
be a little bit more moderate we've got
an election going on and that's the
debate that's going on noam chomsky
who's a radical
leftist and public intellectual for the
last 700 years
he just got into a bit of a debate about
this sort of issue
with a radical leftist from the bernie
sanders campaign
and chomsky actually played the role of
the moderate here because chomsky
understands in politics
you don't win by losing what you're
saying
if you think it through is we should
help
trump win because maybe in the long run
that'll affect the democratic party
that's a terrible choice
helping trump win as you're proposing
would mean four more years of
destruction of the environment
getting possibly the tipping points that
which would be irreversible
certainly making any effort to deal with
it very difficult
it would mean stacking the judiciary
with young ultra-right lawyers
top to bottom so that nothing would be
possibly done for a generation
and i can go on and on i don't think
that's a wise choice
just on the hope that maybe sometime in
the long term
the democratic party will pay attention
to the fact that you're
part of the 50 of non-voters a great
point and the woman that he was speaking
with
pushed back said no the time is now
we've got to take a stand and kill our
chances of winning
in this election and then later maybe
we'll win the never trump right made the
same argument in 2016. and i understand
the appeal of the argument the appeal is
okay things aren't going the way i want
them to
so the best thing to do is to lose it's
better to lose and then
regroup and then in four years or eight
years then we can win
you know winning is a little tricky i
like the idea that people who
can't win now are going to tell us how
to win in four years or eight years
that's not how it works politics is a
messy thing
the way you win is by winning
and when you lose you can't predict
what's going to happen next
you've got to take the wins as you get
them that's why
the smarter people in the democratic
party realize
we've really got to win this thing we're
really on the ropes here we can't just
count on what happens
after this aberration of a politician
donald trump
goes away that's why i think they're
going to hang back on the amy barrett
hearings i don't think
it's going to be a particularly vicious
hearing at least compared to
say brett kavanaugh i think they know
they've lost this thing and they
they don't really care about this seat
all that much they want to keep their
eyes on the prize
on november 3rd and the judiciary might
play a role in that if they challenge it
in court so in any case we're headed for
a mess
and i don't think any side is going to
throw up their hands and say we'll win
it next time they know we've got to win
it
now that's our show on michael knowles
it's the michael show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wodowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton